you know who's next make some noise
start it now for markiplier hello
welcome welcome welcome why is there
another microphone there
I probably just screwed up the whole
show by doing that for hello hi how's it
going my name is markiplier and I'm here
to share something with you when they
asked me to come out on this stage I
knew that it was going to be among other
guests that were much more talented and
able to actually sing and dance and do
things like that oh you know it's true
but the one thing they asked me to do
was share something with you that I love
and as some of you may know as some of
you may not know the one thing that I
really truly love is space a lot of
space lovers out here I love space and
when they ask me to share this thing and
no I'm not going to sing the song sorry
[Applause]
no no no I wanted to tell you guys the
story of why I love space and that
really got me thinking about you know
where that came from where I fostered
this deep connection to what amounts to
a big nothing up there um but it really
does go deep with me because if I were
to tell the story I would have to go
back to my childhood when I was about 12
my parents had just gotten divorced and
we didn't have a lot of money for video
games but my dad bought me this game
called home world and I don't know if
you guys know about this game it's
alright if you don't but it's basically
a game about space and I loved it I
loved it number one because
dad spent what little money he had on
this game for me to enjoy and number two
it was really a good game so I played
the crap out of it the music was great
the art was great the vastness of it was
wonderful but twelve year old me really
didn't appreciate it for what it was at
the time so I played it through a couple
times and then shelved it for later the
next time that I thought about it was
about a week after my dad passed away I
was I was in still in shock I hadn't let
myself grieve about it and I found
myself I was working a deck building job
as some of you may know and I went up to
my boss because that particular day I
was feeling really off and as I should
and I told him I needed to take a break
he didn't deserve like I didn't deserve
to be paid if I wasn't going to work
well so I left and I went to my mom's
house and I I laid down in her driveway
and I just stared up and I look at the
Stars
and I stayed there for hours and hours
and I was just comforted by the
emptiness of it you know I wasn't
looking for any answers I wasn't looking
for anything to shout out at me I was
just looking up because I needed the
silence I needed the solace I needed the
solitude I and then I had a thought
something I hadn't thought about since I
was a child I thought about that game
and I realized that I really wanted to
play it again and I wasn't sure why I
wanted to play it again I just had to
play it again so I went over to my step
mom and dad's house and in their
basement my dad was a creature of habit
he stored everything meticulously that
he ever had every book that he read
every book that he published every every
piece of cookware that was passed down
to our family old grills that didn't
work anymore you know but in the back in
the very back among all these
bookshelves
was a game shelf within meticulous order
every single game that he had bought me
over the years and walking in I didn't
realize it and it wasn't until I pulled
that game from the shelf and I looked
back and I saw this catalog of my dad's
life that I realized just how much I
missed him and so I broke down and I was
crying and crying but then I open the
game and this is one game boxes used to
be big so it's big big instruction
manual pop the CD and install it back in
days when you had to install games of
CDs and then I played it and I was loved
I loved everything about it and I was
grown up enough to appreciate how big it
was out there and then when I came back
from playing the game I was like 16
hours straight just stuck in my my
stepmoms basement just playing over and
over again
crying intermittently and then just
though I and then I went back outside it
was dark and I looked up and it didn't
seem empty anymore it was everything I
understood how vast it really was and I
understood how big it was and how small
I am and that's not a short joke it's a
short trip
but that's when I realized that I had to
let my dad go and I gained an
appreciation for something that's so
much bigger than myself so anyway that's
what I wanted to share with you thank
you everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
you